we're all the same some of us just dress
better
so it's not like I'm better than the
people on the show this is a ride and
we're all incredibly lucky Jerry
Springer has died he was 79 years old
a family spokesperson says Jerry died in
his Chicago area home after battling a
brief illness I've always defended the
show
because they may do things that are
inappropriate or wrong or they may be
poor
may be uneducated they're not trash the
human beings let's not be too quick to
judge Jerry hosted his hit syndicated
talk show The Jerry Springer Show for 27
years known for its outrageous guests
and audience chance
but before he was a TV icon Jerry was a
politician running a failed campaign for
U.S Congress in 1970. I was very active
in the anti-war movement and that was my
passion right out of law school I went
to work for Bobby Kennedy I decided to
run for the United States Congress
as an anti-war candidate the day before
with the shootings at Kent State
in Ohio
the outrage of that
resulted in me winning the Democratic
primary he was elected to Cincinnati
City Council in 1971 and became their
mayor in 1977 serving one term when that
term ended
NBC had come to me and they said why
don't you anchor our news in Cincinnati
the Jerry Springer Show debuted in 1991
and originally focused on political
issues the NBC affiliate there they
owned Phil Donahue Sally Jessa Raphael
and one day the CEO took me out to lunch
and said we're going to start another
talk show and you're going to host it
it wasn't anything I ever aspired to it
wasn't anything I know anything about I
was assigned to host the show in the
show suddenly took off and here I am the
show aired its final episode in 2018.
when I signed it was a side job I just
signed for six weeks so there was no
expectation but it just keeps lasting
it's fun to do I enjoy it it's a it's a
circus it's an Escape his courtroom show
Judge Jerry ran for three seasons next
time that happens call them an Uber
and his last TV appearance was on The
Masked Singer in 2022 where he performed
as the beatle and sang A Frank Sinatra
classic
[Music]
Jerry is survived by his daughter Katie
and Sister Evelyn I didn't grow up
wanting to be an Entertainer
so I'm lucky
um because the truth is anybody can be a
talk show host you do three things to be
a talk show host you have to be able to
say you did what come on out we'll be
right back if you can do those three
lines you've got a career I know what
I'm going to put on my Tombstone I won't
be right back